well the results today show that we the
plane that we have with the Bank of
England is satisfactory to them we still
have some actions to take that we agreed
to last year but what was really
pleasing was that the bank showed such a
improvement over the last year and over
the last 24 months and it shows that
even under a very severe test of you
know 40% reduction and commercial
property 30 odd percent reduction in
house prices doubling of unemployment
the bank would still be in sound
condition and that's something that I've
been building since my tenure in the job
recreate a bank that was secure that the
public of the UK did not have to worry
about this bank and I think today just
shows another step forward now as you
say you've spent a lot of time at the
last four years detoxifying the bank
offloading toxic assets I mean the one
big legacy issue you still have is this
settlement with the US Justice
Department over the mis-selling of
mortgage back securities any clue on
when that's going to happen well
unfortunately there isn't any further
discussions going on and there at the
moment there's something that we would
like to clean up and we've see it once
we have tidied up the Department of
Justice fine that this bank will be back
in profit so it's something that we do
want to do as as quickly as possible but
unfortunately not one not in my time
gift and of course bringing it back into
profit means I mean we heard from a
Philip Hammond last year the Treasury is
looking to raise 15 billion from selling
RBS shares over the next five years that
can't go ahead until the glj settlement
presumably well what we showed even in
the first three quarters of this year
that the bank is a really sound
profitable business three-quarters of
profit and it and once we are through
the Department of Justice fine I think
the government is in a very sound
position to actually start selling off
at shears had shown last week the
Chancellor said that he was keen to do
that he believed the bank wasn't good
enough shape to start that process in
the 2018 and 2019 fiscal year and I
think that was good news for the public
of the UK to know that this bank is in
pretty good shape now the other big
legacy issue with which you're still
grappling to an extent global
restructuring group this was your
restructuring unit tipped thousands of
small businesses into liquidation the
essays published a summary of a report
today
on what happened should they publish the
full report well I think the summary
which has had a Queen's Counsel look
through it on behalf of the Treasury
select committee said that the summary
did reflect fairly what was in the
report the danger and putting out what
we call these ace 166 reports as once
you've put one out how many do you put
out and going forward so I think that's
the reservation as opposed to this
specific report but the report did show
quite clearly that we didn't get
everything right here there were some
things that you know we have apologised
for there are some actions that we're
taking as far as putting a place like
proper complaints process that are set
over the top of by a high court judge so
that we look at every case and say did
we get this right or wrong and if we got
it wrong putting it right
we've also gone through three and a half
thousand of the customers that were in
this global restructuring group and
refunded with interest all of the
complex fee structures that they paid as
well because again we weren't
comfortable with it the report showed
that we didn't get that right so we are
trying to move forward on behalf of our
customers and and of the bank we just
didn't get a ride okay now what about
the outlook for 2018 I mean we heard
some fairly downbeat comments from the
Office of Budget Responsibility last
night Morgan Stanley on the show last
night said they expect growth to be even
lower than that what are you thinking
well what's been really interested the
economy has been very robust even with
this uncertainty of bricks that hanging
over and yes the the report showed for
for next year probably one to 1.2
percent GDP growth but it's it's I've
just been so surprised how resilient the
economy has been the consumers are still
feeling pretty good about the what's
going on the exporters we see in 2018
will actually kick in because of the
lower pound and probably take over some
of the work that the consumer has been
doing so probably not as downbeat as
many others are about it as long as
we're getting growth in the economy
you've got growth going on in Europe
you've got very strong growth going on
in the United States we trade with these
partners people in these areas so I
don't think it's as bad as people have
thought but look who knows what could
happen if we get a very harsh brexit
very briefly Ross you just clocked up
four
is in arguably one of the most grueling
jobs in in British business you recently
linked with a job down under
Commonwealth Bank of Australia what's
wrong are you gonna be sticking around
for I'd like to see us through have
talked about getting the share sale get
back in place I'd love to see this bank
back paying a dividend to all those
shareholders they've been hanging on for
such a long period of time we've got I
think in my Tim of some period of time
to actually really get this Bank back
into good form so that the public of the
UK are really proud of it again we've
got a lot of work to do around our
customers you know we're making major
changes to the way we're operating the
business because their customers
behavior is changing around branches and
those sort of activities as they move
more and more digitally so lots of
things to be done as of yet all right
good to see we haven't seen the back of
you yet Ross McEwan thanks for joining
me thank you very much